my series healthy habits for 2022
continues this morning today it's about
making your moves so how much do you
move around through the day have you
ever noticed and i don't mean that you
have to hit the gym or run five miles
some simple movements can be very
effective and it could be the secret to
your longevity
small bounce of movement throughout the
day
that's the way that your body circulates
fluids and you know engages your
neurological tissue and it makes you
more cognitively clear
and just a functional human being
whether you just want to be functional
or extra fit movement coach aaron
alexander says we have to move around to
keep our bodies and minds in shape even
little actions make a big difference the
term for
small movements throughout the day is
fancy term is called neat non-exercise
activity thermogenesis
and very fancy and
what that is is all the little fidgets
and kind of wiggles and twists and turns
and you get up and walk and get some
coffee and you you know take a walk on
your cell phone as you're talking to
somebody erin says the more neat you
have in your day the more calories you
can burn while giving your body and
joints an easy workout but for avid
exercisers who often max out your moves
he warns learn to set boundaries for
pain your body has a really clever
simple easy way of saying there's a
position that's not good for you and it
hurts like muscle burn is completely
different than joint strain
so you will not heal your joints by
going into the pain in the joint going
around the pain incredibly valuable he
also shared that most of us overlook a
very basic principle of movement that
might seem unnatural just the value of
spending time a little bit of time on
the ground each day
so if you ever do a yoga class or maybe
like a pilates or a martial arts class
or jiu jitsu you will be on the ground a
lot and that valuable getting up and
down motion aaron says could keep your
body nimble for a lifetime so what i'd
recommend is in your home have a space
that you can
comfortably get up and down off of the
ground
throw some floor cushions down you know
maybe put a yoga mat down someplace so
it's inviting you to get all the way
down to that range of motion get a
really comfortable rug and by doing that
you're going to start to be implementing
these little doses of healing motion
into your ankles into your knees into
your hips into your spine your pelvic
floor
and that leads to you know a successful
life
okay i'm gonna have to practice that a
little bit more getting up and down
it takes practice for sure aaron has
been practicing his techniques for more
than a decade now he's the creator of
the align method it's a way to age proof
your body through movement and training
it's all his own he's ha he's has a book
he has a podcast if you'd like to check
it out
we'll have that information on our
website and that's eightnewsnow.com
lots of good things in the conversation
so
i learned a lot john yeah